americans are already showing their
determination to have their votes
counted with the election just 20 days
away
we are looking at huge turnout and
massive lines in places where early
voting is an option that includes texas
and georgia and both of those states are
predicted to be closely fought for the
first time
in decades they're also dealing with
allegations of voter suppression
omar villafranca is at a polling
location in dallas texas omar good
morning to you
what are voters telling you good morning
some people are telling me they vote
early because they want to watch all the
election results come in
on election day and some people also
feel so passionate about this election
they didn't want to wait
in fact one county in texas had about
the same amount of early voters
as the whole state of georgia on its
first day
long lines greeted texans looking to
vote early in the lone star state
this is probably the most important
election i've ever been a part of and i
want
to know that my vote's going to be
counted so i came out the first day
why wait till last minute i don't
procrastinate
one reason for the long lines roughly 3
million
new voters have registered since the
last presidential election
in travis county where the city of
austin is officials say
97 percent of eligible voters have
registered
compared with an average of about 67
percent nationwide
in harris county more than 128 thousand
voted early
smashing the old record of 68 thousand
but a federal appeals court sided with
republican governor greg abbott
to limit the number of drop-off
locations to one per county
abbott said it was needed for election
security but harris county judge lena
hidalgo
calls it voter suppression i don't see a
legitimate reason
i think it's completely illogical
you're my first call famous faces like
oprah winfrey and dallas mavericks owner
mark cuban
were busy urging texans to get out and
vote if you haven't voted early yet come
down to the aac
at the state farm arena in atlanta
almost 3
000 people voted early with lunchtime
voters in and out in about 20 minutes
but elsewhere in georgia technical
glitches and high turnout have led to
some wait times of
more than five hours cbs news election
law expert david becker
they're coming with stools and they're
coming with snacks and they're coming
with books and
they're ready they want to make their
voice heard
polls open in less than an hour here in
texas and there's already a line
forming behind me here in virginia
tuesday was the final day for voter
registration
but a cable was cut and the whole system
was shut down statewide the aclu has
filed a lawsuit they want to extend that
deadline
and the governor agrees with it but it
appears it will be
up to the courts gail can you imagine
the guy that cut the cable oops
thank you very much omar